so treasury and commerce department okay
your request the next step is we
mentioned is to get the okay from Cuba
can you tell us what the approval
process is like from Cuba's government
and when you're likely to get it a good
morning Scarlett yeah we're excited it's
a privilege to receive the licenses from
the Treasury Department in the Commerce
Department we're very excited at the
same time you know we are working with
the Cubans to get what we need from them
so we can actually honor our intent
which is to sell in May of 2016 with our
favim brand about 700 guests every other
week insecure and you mentioned the farm
brand that's one of the newest brands
you have in your portfolio tell us how
that branch is a good fit with an
education or humanitarian voyage to Cuba
as you know Scarlett we have ten brands
and Fatima's our newest which we lost
just a few weeks ago it evolved from an
original intent to have a sustainable
systematic social impact it's targeting
initially at the end of Dominican
Republic the Porta Potty region where
travelers will have the opportunity to
be enriched by working alongside
Dominicans who have a real track record
of social transformation in a community
in the areas of environment and
education and economic development with
Cuba of course is a little different as
cultural exchanges immersion in human
society is the first time in 50 years
scarlet where a ship will be able to go
from the US carrying passengers to Cuba
and then to return and repeat that
process and so we feel privileged to
have received the US licenses and are
excited about working with the Cubans to
ensure that we do everything possible so
we can sell in May of 2016 mr. Donald
certainly you guys have done a lot of
due diligence you've done your research
or marketing research what does all your
studies show you or indicate when it
comes to what travelers want to get out
of a trip to Cuba and how does it break
down when it comes to baby boomers for
instance versus say Millennials well you
know in the US there's so much pense up
to man and
curiosity about Cuba and so we're very
much looking forward to honoring what
guests and travelers are seeking which
is basically immersion in the Cuban
culture to just experience it the arts
you know the food the environmental work
that's already going on in Cuba the
other cultural exchange aspects and
education and religion and so that's
what people are seeking whether it's
Millennials or whether it's people who
are older and have traveled and regular
tours you know this type of a cultural
exchange excursion there's high demand
especially for Cuba but we also know
there's a real demand for our Dominican
Republic itineraries as well mr. Donald
can you tell me about the existing
infrastructure in Havana to accommodate
large cruise ships like the fathom what
kind of additional investment will be
needed for you to be able to make this
happen well at this stage the fathom is
using one of our piano ships is being
redeployed as the adonia beautiful ship
carries about 700 guests and the ship of
that size we already have charted on the
waters of course when you do some
additional work before we sell in May of
2016 but where you know definitely can
see that ship being readily accommodated
a number of ports over time once the
embargo is lifted and we see this as a
first step not just us but for the
industry overall obviously to take the
larger ships in port development will
have to occur the Cubans are very much
aware of that and we look forward to
working with them along with others in
our industry to do just that yeah
exactly Norwegian Cruise Line has said
also that it too is looking to enter the
Cuban market